[Musique]
après l'intervention du président
Emmanuel Macron les opposants à la
réforme des retraites continues de se
mobiliser du côté des transports le
trafic était très perturbé ce jeudi 23
mars dans les Yvelines notamment sur la
ligne C où il fallait prévoir un train
sur trois du côté des raffineries 14 %
des stations dans le département était
en pénurie d'au moins un carburant dont
4% en pénurie totale et du côté de
l'éducation 25% des enseignants se sont
déclarés grévistes dans les écoles
primaires et les collèges et ils étaient
20% dans les lycées selon les chiffres
de l'académie de Versailles
ce jeudi 23 mars à l'initiative de la
CGT des opposants à la réforme des
retraites ont manifesté ils étaient à la
gare de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à 10h
et se sont rendus au siège du Medef à
Guyancourt la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites va peut-être
obligé les autorités à modifier le
programme de la venue du roi
d'Angleterre à Paris ce dernier devait
dîner au château de Versailles ce lundi
27 mars mais le contexte politique a
bouleversé les choses le dîner pourrait
finalement se tenir à l'Élysée l'édition
2023 du site d'action aura lieu les 24
25 et 26 mars prochain comme chaque
année trois jours de mobilisation de
sensibilisation et de collecte sont
prévus auprès du grand public et si vous
aussi vous souhaitez soutenir la
recherche vous pouvez appeler le Sandy
ou faire un ton directement sur le site
internet www.org
car le livre est allé rendre visite au
pape avec le variété Club de France
accompagné d'Aix gloire du football le
député yvelinois remis au pape François
1er un maillot de l'équipe siglée du
numéro 10 le variété a ensuite affronté
ce mercredi une équipe du Saint Siège et
l'emportait sur le score de 8 à 2
[Musique]